salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui on va
parler de l'idéologie wok une idéologie
qui si on écoute certains à gauche
n'existerait pas elle ne modifierait pas
le corpus doctrinal des organisations de
gauche et d'extrême gauche et
n'enverrait pas les sphères médiatiques
intellectuels et universitaires
elle serait simplement une forme de
fantasmes de l'extrême droite et
pourtant cette idéologie qui est censée
ne pas exister eh bien parfois fini par
exaspérer les militants au sein de
certaines organisations de gauche et
d'extrême gauche qui finissent par
claquer la porte et aujourd'hui je vous
propose de découvrir et d'analyser une
lettre écrit par des militants
anarchistes qui ont décidé de quitter
leurs organisations l'union communiste
libertaire cette lettre est extrêmement
intéressante parce qu'elle nous montre
comment de l'intérieur les militants
vivre l'arrivée de ces idéologies et
comment elle modifie les rapports de
force mais aussi les rapports humains et
tout d'abord avant d'entamer l'analyse
de ce document quelques informations
générales pour comprendre le contexte
l'union communiste libertaire dont il va
être question est une organisation
anarchiste qui était ces dernières
années la plus importante sur la scène
française elle était née en 2019 elle
est issue de la fusion de la
coordination des groupes anarchistes et
d'alternative libertaire ce sont deux
organisations anarchistes qui se
revendiquait notamment du courant
communiste libertaire dont je vous
renvoie à la vidéo que j'ai fait sur les
courants anarchiste pour plus
d'informations sur ce point et notamment
alternative libertaire était une
organisation qui se tournaient
clairement vers le marxisme certains se
revendiquer d'une forme de marxisme
libertaire et souvent même préféré
travailler avec les marxistes et les
trotskistes plutôt qu'avec les anars qui
trouvait un petit peu folklo et secteur
la coordination des groupes anarchistes
elle a subi une scission il ya quelques
années en 2015 au moment de charlie
hebdo et bien parce que ils avaient
refusé de prendre position sur justement
sur charlie hebdo et une partie avait
quitté l'organisation en dénonçant une
forme d'islam au gauchisme et donc ces
deux organisations ont fusionné en 2019
parce qu'elle avait atteint une forme de
plafond de verre et elles ont donné
naissance à l'union communiste
libertaire qui est donc une organisation
qui devait avoir autour de 400 personnes
et qui a apparemment eu si on en croit
les communiqués une dynamique a dû
monter jusqu'à 500 ou 600 personnes au
niveau national
également dans ce genre de textes de
démission collective qu'on trouve
parfois aussi à l'extrême gauche il ya
souvent des allusions à des événements
un petit peu obscur ou des points de
doctrine particulier heureusement pour
nous il se trouve donc que j'ai milité
il ya longtemps et bien au sein de la
mouvance libertaire et notamment au sein
des deux organisations qui ont fusionné
pour donner naissance à l'union
communiste libertaire et donc je suis
toujours un petit peu de loin par
curiosité l'actualité de cette
organisation est donc je pourrais
apporter quelques éléments pour rendre
un petit peu plus compréhensible les
différentes allusion qui sont faites
dans ce texte bref maintenant que la
mise au point est fait et bien passons à
l'analyse du texte lui-même alors ce
texte est relativement court il fait
8000 signe c'est à dire à peine deux
pages de textes au format excel
personnellement pour alléger la vidéo je
vais me concentrer sur les paragraphes
qui nous parle du gaullisme mais je vous
mettrai le lien pour lire du texte en
descriptions sous la vidéo pour ceux que
ça intéresse alors ce texte s'intitule
nous quittons le cl pour des motifs
politiques et quelques remarques d'abord
sur le chapeau en introduction qui est
en italie qu il nous dit militantes et
militants communistes libertaires depuis
des années plus de 40 ans pour certains
nous avons assisté à une transformation
profonde de notre organisation ce qui
aurait pu nous convenir mais l'union
communiste libertaire créé il ya deux
ans met à mal les relations humaines qui
si nous adoptons un fonctionnement qui
ne recherche ni le respect de ses textes
fondateurs ni celui de ses valeurs et ne
favorise pas la solidarité militante
leur première chose effectivement quand
on regarde les signataires on voit que
enfin j'ai pu identifier une ou deux
personnes qui effectivement militait au
sein d' alternative libertaire parmi les
signataires qui sont une trentaine qui
effectivement été engagée depuis les
années 80 90
également il faut noter que l'ont
manifestement canton quand on dit ce
texte et qu'on connaît un peu le milieu
ce sont les gens de l'est plus à droite
d'alternative libertaire l'acquis
qui scissionne très clairement
et ces gens ne sont pas des
gestionnaires professionnels
contrairement à l'image qu'on a des
libertaires des anars qui voit la
quittent leur organisation en claquant
la porte dès qu'ils sont pas d'accord
sur un petit point la particularité
d'alternative libertaire c'est d'avoir
existé sous une forme ou une autre parce
qu'à changer de trois fois de nom
d'exister depuis 1976 et depuis cette
date elle n'a jamais connu de cession
c'est-à-dire de départs collectifs comme
ça pour des désaccords politiques
majeures
c'était une organisation extrêmement
stable de ce côté là parce qu elle est l
interface entre les libertaires et les
marxistes et donc qu'ils avaient
naturellement une forme de biens de
culture un petit peu du débat ce qui
faisait défaut ailleurs et donc ces gens
clairement un pour certains qui militait
depuis des années au sein de cette
structure la
fondue scission pour la première fois de
leur vie exploitait un véritable crève
coeur d'amour donné ce qui pour certains
est l'oeuvre de toute une vie
également on voit des 17 introductions
qu'on nous parle parle des relations
humaines qui qui se nouent au sein de
l'organisation
habituellement quand des gens une faune
des textes comme ça de scission ils vont
nous récapituler tous les points de
désaccord idéologique depuis dix ans et
là on nous parle d'un autre domaine
alors on va aussi nous parler de ces
questions idéologiques mais on nous
parle là des domaines des relations
humaines manifestement
les conflit dégénère pas seulement d'un
point de vue idéologique mais met aussi
vraiment à mal
tout le tissu social interne à
l'organisation
et ça je pense que c'est assez important
pour être souligné ce que j'ai
réellement jour de textes les relations
humaines elle est question du lien
social ne sont jamais évoqués
alors les premiers paragraphes ne nous
intéressent clairement pas puisqu'ils
sont avant tout destinées au mouvement
libertaire ils sont là pour que les
cessionnaires se positionne au sein de
cette mouvance dont manifestement oui ce
qu'ils disent ils sont très clairement
l aile droite
le premier paragraphe qui nous intéresse
est ici il nous dit à lui c'est elle
aujourd'hui la lutte de classe est
systématiquement opposé à
l'intersexualité alors que pour nous
toutes les luttes peuvent être articulé
ensemble donc la première évocation des
donc du work is main avec une opposition
entre la lutte des classes et la notion
d' intersexualité
opposition idéologique frontale puisque
traditionnellement dans les
organisations d'extrême gauche considère
que l'aide des classes et la forme
d'exploitation centrale même si il lutte
aussi pour l'écologie ou contre le
sexisme tout ça on sait dire quand même
que la lutte des classes enfin que quel
capitalisme la lutte économique est
primordiale puisque c'est le système
économique qui sous tend un peu les
autres domination donc fatalement à son
à bas le capitalisme on affaiblit les
autres domination avec la notion d'
intersexualité c'est une logique
totalement opposés ou en fin de compte
toutes les luttes se valent et sont à
égalité les intersectionnelle celle les
orifices alors hérisse le poil quand on
leur dit qu'il faut hiérarchiser les
luttes donc là on a eu certainement avec
l introduction de nouvelles idées un
conflit ne serait ce que sur cette
notion de quelle lutte est prioritaire
ensuite on nous dit les postures
radicales ou plus exactement des
discours prétendument radicaux ne
remplace pas les engagements concrets en
lien direct avec les classes populaires
qu'ils soient associatifs syndicaux
politiques ancrées dans les quartiers
les villes et les campagnes cela se
complète avec une incapacité d'écouté et
d'empathie qui contrarie notre
implication sociale au contraire
l'utilisation d'un langage élitiste ne
peut que renforcer la domination sur
celles et ceux qui ne maîtrisent pas
alors là on a une opposition un petit
peu classique dans ce genre de texte
entre d'un côté des gens qui sont dans
le réel qui font qu'ils sont infractions
et d'autre des gens qui sont dans le
discours alors on voit notamment le la
critique d'un langage élitiste un tour
ce langage ou au qu'avec ce jargon ces
termes pseudo scientifiques qui font
intelligent
alors pour le coup c'est pas faux seins
cette opposition idéologique d'un côté
et de l'autre côté l'action puisque les
gens d'alternative libertaire était très
tournées justement sur ces milieux
associatifs syndicaux ce que appelé dans
leur jargon de leur analyse la gauche de
la rue et puis toujours un set cette
accusation qui revient avec le gothisme
de postures radicales de discours
radicaux plus que d'engagements concrets
ensuite on a une critique sur un élément
qui est tout autre qui est la question
des religions on nous dit quant à la
critique de toutes les religions incarné
depuis toujours par le mouvement
libertaire elle est devenue taboue et
donne même lieu à des accusations de
racisme lorsqu'elle est proposée alors
que le manifeste de mc elle rappelle son
engagement à défendre un projet de
société libérée de l'aliénation
religieuse même si la liberté de croire
ou non doit être défendue et libertaires
se sont toujours dressés contre toutes
les formes d'oppression religieuses
notamment chrétienne juive et musulmane
concernant concernant l'islamophobie
dont nous ne sommes pas dupes ça ne doit
toutefois pas conduire à exclure toute
réflexion critique quand l'islam
politique est au pouvoir dans certains
pays où qu'ils menacent les droits et
les libertés dans le monde où ici donc
la no démissionnaire et bien formule une
critique comme quoi certaines religions
ou plutôt une certaine religion l'islam
et bien n'a plus le droit d'être
critiqué au sein de l'organisation
fait qui est
dénoncé par une partie du spectre
politique depuis des années et dont là
on a effectivement une confirmation on
n'a plus le droit de critiquer l'islam
et même l'islam politique qui est
pourtant en est une est une idéologie
extrêmement rétrograde et puis ensuite
on entre un petit peu dans le vif du
sujet j'ai envie de dire on nous dit
cette organisation plus est elle donc
accepté le principe d'une communication
interne violente où le débat n'est plus
nourrie par des points de vue politique
mais s'exprime par anathème à partir
d'une essentialisation des militants
ainsi ce n'est plus tant ce qui est
argumenté que la personne qui parle
défini par sa couleur de peau son âge
son genre etc or les personnes doivent
être reconnus dans leurs propos et leurs
actes et non par la liste des
dominations vécu quand on vécu et au
ressenti s'ils ont une place ils ne
justifient pas l'imposition d'une ligne
politique
donc là très clairement un dénonciation
de cette essentialisation de ce
assignation identitaire que
qu'impose c'est cette idéologie post
moderne avec voilà la définition de
l'individu par des critères qui ne sont
en rien liées à sa volonté
son appartenance ethnique son genre sur
l'orientation sexuelle
et puis également à cette dénonciation
aussi toujours de ceux ressentis qui est
mise toujours sur un piédestal par cette
idéologie aucun le ressenti sera une
vérité absolue surtout quand il est
formulé par par des personnes qui
seraient qui seraient dominés également
un petit peu plus loin on nous dit que
est bien l ucl aujourd'hui il y a des
gens qui s'expriment ils sont surtout
celles et ceux qui sont maîtres du temps
et adepte des faux procès les autres
n'ayant comme choix que de chaudes subir
l'opprobre publique de tours s'auto
censurer ou de se taire donc là on voit
que l'arrivée de ces idéologies un très
clairement ne se fait pas dans un débat
démocratique et pour ces gens
d'alternative libertaire qui sont
habitués aux débats internes et à
l'acceptation de deux positions
différentes ça doit faire un petit peu
un choc de voir que ces gens ont des
méthodes clairement là ce qui est décrit
dans ce paragraphe c c'est clairement
cette menace que fait peser la quand
c'est le culture on va le voir
d'ailleurs dans le paragraphe d'après où
les choses sont un petit peu précisé
puisqu'on nous dit des accusations sans
fondement de racisme ou d'antisémitisme
de sexisme de complicité de la culture
du viol de transphobie valley 10 mhz de
plus tôt phobie etc sont proférés sans
argument n'est clés de compréhension
il est pourtant évident que si celles ci
étaient fondées des procédures
d'exclusion auraient été mises en oeuvre
et on ajoute ses propos accusateurs qui
ont pu s'exprimer au dernier congrès
sont sans doute minoritaire il camoufle
en réalité des divergences politiques et
la majorité laisse faire
alors là il faut connaître un petit peu
le ce qui se passe au sein de cette
organisation pour comprendre toutes ces
allusions tout le texte est irrigué tout
entendu mais là c'est particulièrement
flagrant
donc à y faire face que quelques
explications on nous parle par exemple
de la complicité de deux cultures du
viol
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il
ya eu une affaire d'accusations de viol
au sein du lycée elle
qui a été traitée par une commission
spécifique alors dans cette affaire en
fait vous avez un militant qui parfois
bien sûr paris se fait héberger par des
camarades et une fois il se fait
héberger par une camarade ils couchent
ensemble et le lendemain il repart avant
qu'elle se réveille en laissant un petit
mot et elle quand elle se réveille elle
dit ignorer viol ce qui enclenche et
bien au sein de l'ue s'est elle la mise
en place d'une commission denquête
pour régler le problème et en fin de
compte cette commission denquête va
fonctionner avec cette logique aucun qui
d'ailleurs a dénoncé un peu avant dans
le texte de loi le ressenti fait tout
et donc quand une personne dit
je me sent violée ont beaucoup d'heures
il considère qu'il est donc cette
commission a été extrêmement à charge
elle n'a pas écouté les éléments à
décharge apparemment ça extrêmement
brassée en interne ce qui a même eu un
texte avec des gens qui plusieurs
signataires pour dire que voilà cette
commission quand même avait été
extrêmement partiale et est
problématique donc ce qui a dû être
assez peu assez mal vécue par paris ou
et qui est des tests voilà qu'on remette
en question la parole la parole de la
victime de la présumée victime
donc ça lui crée énormément de tension
d'où certainement cette accusation de
complicité de culture du viol est donc
dans cette affaire le type a fini par
être exclu il ya eu des communiqués de
presse on peut facilement trouver son
nom sur internet
et pour plus d'infos jour je vous
renvoie au site qui est un petit peu
analysé cette cette affaire et les
processus qu'il ya eu
également donc c'est cessionnaire nous
disent donc bien une majorité
majorité est silencieuse mais
manifestement n'est pas convaincu par sd
works qui seraient minoritaires alors il
faut savoir qu'au dernier congrès il ya
eu une motion
qui a tenté de réaffirmé la centralité
de la lutte des classes donc opposés aux
notions d'intersection nalité motion qui
d'ailleurs a probablement été en partie
proposée par certains démissionnaires je
suppose et émotion qui n'a récolté que
27% des voix donc la notion de
centralité de la bible des classes n'est
assurée que par 27 % des gens dans cette
organisation qui se dit anti capitaliste
donc parmi les 73 % vous avez des ebooks
et des gens qui manifestement est bien
sont des gens un petit peu lâches qui
n'osent pas assumé leurs leur désaccord
avec ses hôtes
alors là quand même
donc là les démissionnaires se met un
petit peu dans la position de
du courageux face aux gens qui la
majorité silencieuse qui refuse de
prendre position il faut quand même
savoir que ça fait au moins une dizaine
d'années que les démos qui commence à
pointer dans ces milieux personnellement
après une fois que j'ai croisé le terme
hétéro patriarcat c'était en 2010 au
sein de la coordination des groupes
anarchistes et que les éléments
problématiques sont apparues globalement
fin 2014 avec notamment la taille d'une
librairie par des des coloniaux qui
refusait un débat justement sur ces
questions un post moderne et à ce moment
là vous avez plusieurs événements comme
ça donc ces gens qui aujourd'hui nous
disent voilà
la majorité silencieuse se tait nous on
dénonce un peu de fête camarades et j'ai
envie de dire ça fait déjà cinq six ans
que les problèmes sont déjà visibles
dans vos milieux ça fait déjà cinq six
ans vous auriez dû commencer vous même à
vous poser des questions vous avez beau
jeu fin 2021 de claquer la porte de
votre organisation quand vous même vous
êtes personnellement touché par par ces
problèmes mais revenons revenus au texte
ensuite on a quelqu'un paragraphe
extrêmement intéressant qui a revient
sur la question du féminisme et qui nous
dit seulement du patriarcat
postmoderniste semble avoir le vent en
poupe et constituent de fait un bureau
politique qui ne dit pas son nom
minorant ainsi la parole des militantes
qui prennent une approche qui portent
pardon une approche et une méthodologie
autres le genre est en effet devenu le
prisme de tout échange les camarades
hommes hétérosexuels notamment soumis à
une critique du simple fait de ce qu'ils
sont quelles que soient leurs
engagements concrets dans la lutte pour
l'égalité des droits y compris dans leur
vie quotidienne
également dans le dernier vingt
dernières parties on a des éléments plus
généraux mais on nous dit notamment que
de très nombreux et nombreuses camarades
ont déjà quitté l'organisation choqué de
sa violence interne et de sa dérive
politique et puis
les démissionnaires et bien tire le
bilan que la fusion des organisations
n'a pas permis de briser le plafond de
verre mais au contraire a manifestement
fait perdre des militants donc là on a
quand même l'affirmation que au delà des
divergences idéologiques qui vont déjà
ne s'exprime pas de façon démocratique
et apaisé et bien manifestement c'est
cette violence idéologique fait aussi
que des gens finissent par partir
manifestement sur sur la pointe des
pieds là on voit bien quelque part que
est bien avec le cdo qu'on a une
changement de paradigme c'est qu'on n'a
plus d'un côté le progressisme et de
l'autre côté la réaction ou supposés
tels mais on a d'un côté les work et de
l'autre le reste du monde et ce reste du
monde et bien commence au sein même de
l'organisation
ce qui fait que des gens finissent par
être voilà des goûters et finissent par
partir souvent sur la pointe des pieds
alors pour synthétiser que nous disent
ces militants libertaires et bien ils
nous disent que lorsque l'idéologie walk
arrive dans une organisation elle
devient petit à petit majoritaire
chassant les anciennes croyances et ce
de façon pas forcément très démocratique
d'abord et valises et d'une forme de
domination avec tout son jargon pseudo
scientifique elle a aussi mené des
chasses aux sorcières en accusant les
gens de sexisme voir ici de puteaux
phobie c'est à dire qu'en fin de compte
elle va menacer les gens de l'est quand
celle de mettre en oeuvre cette fameuse
quand cette culture
ce qui fait que les militants qui ne
sont pas d'accord vont finir soit parce
terre soit par partir collectivement ou
individuellement
également il est intéressant de noter
que manifestement si on en croit ces
gens le féminisme postmoderne tient une
place particulière au sein de la
mouvance rock il a l'air de dominer
d'une tête on va dire les les autres
grilles d'interprétation
et puis tout cela s'accompagne également
manifestement d'une tolérance et d'un
refus de critiques de l'islam
personnellement ce que je trouve amusant
et l'étonnant est bien c'est que
manifestement des militants d'extrême
gauche reprennent les mêmes critiques
que l'ensemble du spectre politique
vis-à-vis de ces idéologies book
manifestement quand on y est confronté
ou qu'on se situe sur le spectre
politique on voit les mêmes choses et
les mêmes dérives comme quoi il doit
bien y avoir une forme de vérité absolue
dans dans ses critiques
également je pense que ce genre de texte
est extrêmement important puisque il
vient dé la gauche elle-même est
peut-être et bien qu à force d'en voir
certains à gauche finiront par se poser
des questions sur l'idéologie aucun
puisque
également je pense que ce genre de texte
est important parce qu'il vient de la
gauche elle-même et peut-être qu'à force
de voir ce genre de critiques émergé en
son sein certains à gauche et bien
finiront par se poser des questions sur
l'effet délétère de ces idéologies look
et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que je
vous invite à partager ce texte dont
vous trouverez le lien en descriptions
bref j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
intéressé si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
à partager et aux abonnés à la chaîne
est sûre ça je vous dis à la prochaine